[Musique]
salut les carrelages Salut les Terriens
très heureux de vous retrouver notre
invité principale ce soir c'est
Dominique saoudien
bonsoir
Dominique vous êtes ici ce soir pour la
sortie de votre nouveau film l'amour
c'est mieux à deux mais je tiens à dire
tout de suite que l'amour c'est mieux à
deux n'a aucun rapport avec les rumeurs
qui ont touché le couple Sarkozy ces
dernières semaines
alors Dominique vous connaissez
l'émission en paix nous serons tous les
deux nous parlerons de vous de vos
origines de votre enfance de votre
adolescence de vos débuts de votre
carrière de la Légion d'honneur que
Nicolas Sarkozy vous a remises en
décembre dernier et depuis rien pas de
médaille pas une carte postale Orléans
rien du tout pas un coup de fil rien
c'est pour ça sinon vous aurez donné la
croix de guerre
en P2 nous accueillerons deux nouveaux
invités pour commentaires avec nous
l'actualité de la télé Hervé Bourges
président du Comité permanent de la
diversité de France Télévisions qui
viennent faire un rapport où il constate
qu'il n'y a pas assez de noir et d'arabe
à France Télévisions en même temps c'est
normal
il y avait Rachid arabes
alors toujours en paix de nous recevrons
Christophe allévêque pour ciao amore la
pièce qui l'interprète à la gaieté
Montparnasse difficile de s'appeler à
les vacances de pédophilie il se marre
pas du tout je vais vous dire l'émission
s'appelle Salut les terriens et le
groupe élément de fortune
[Musique]
alors Dominique Farrugia rebonsoir votre
nouveau film s'appelle l'amour c'est
mieux à deux vous n'êtes pas toujours
dit ça Dominique
non mais j'ai été j'ai été comme tout le
monde mais voilà on se casse voilà donc
c'est un film qui est réalisé à deux
avec Arnaud le mort où l'on trouve
Clovis Cornillac Virginie Efira Manu
Payet
alors le pire c'est deux amis d'enfance
Clovis et Manu qui ont deux visions
diamétralement opposées sur les femmes
Clovis rêve de rencontrer le grand amour
et Manu lui au contraire il pense que
les hommes ont un sexe à la place du
cerveau voilà alors ils vont découvrir
les limites de leur raisonnement au
contact de Virginie Efira et Anne-Lise M
c'est ça c'est une comédie romantique
mais avec de l'humour quand même ah oui
des gros bouts de comédie et on se parle
de tout alors 10 ans après la stratégie
de l'échec vous voilà redevenu
réalisateur la barbe c'est un hommage à
Steven Spielberg ou accubrick
oh c'est gentil non non c'est parce que
vous m'avez retiré ma carte après le
réalisateur et là on me l'a donné donc
j'ai retrouvé mes points alors on
regarde à quoi ça ressemble
c'est le hasard qui détermine les
grandes histoires d'amour depuis
toujours tu me bassines avec tes
théories à deux balles sur l'amour la
rencontre parfaite c'est ce que disent
de nous on a un sexe à la place du
cerveau
[Musique]
un quart d'heure pourquoi moi j'ai pas
droit à ma rencontre avec une femme qui
me plaît bon bah maladie bah oui on dit
toujours santé alors maladie ça change
un peu
moi le prochain que je chope je lui
donne pas plus de 5 minutes pour me
faire bouffer l'oreiller c'est grave
grave en manque c'est clair ça fait un
peu princesse Léa dans Star Wars
[Musique]
c'est le coup de foudre
[Applaudissements]
tellement belle tellement douce
je peux frapper
[Musique]
je suis sûre que c'est quelqu'un qui
demande qu'à révélé la partie sensible
de son âme
[Musique]
faut que tu regardes comme une [__]
madame
[Musique]
j'ai envie de vous dire bravo j'ai pris
une leçon de droit d'éloquence
[Musique]
allez redis-moi le nom parce qu'on a été
coupé
[Applaudissements]
en salle actuellement c'est très marrant
je voulais passer un bon moment allez-y
et la musique c'était maroon five
il y a plein de bons titres dedans
d'acheter des des titres qui me
plaisaient j'avais prévu déjà les titres
avant de tourner bravo ça mérite la
Légion d'honneur à une poitrine quand je
pense à votre Légion d'honneur c'est
bien la preuve qu'on peut prendre de la
drogue baiser des filles faire des
blagues à la con et réussir sa vie
finalement Dominique oui mais il y a eu
il y a eu deux vies oui il y a eu la
première vie donc il y a une deuxième
vie deuxième vie voilà plus à droite
avec les petits enfants ma petite Mia et
la prochaine qui arrive et la prochaine
qui arrive oui c'est un scoop ma femme
me dit dit qu'on a un prochaine enfant
autrement on n'aura pas de cadeau alors
mial à la prochaine elle va s'appeler
comment je peux pas dire c'est pas
encore en combat avec ma femme en grec
ça veut dire première Mia je sais voilà
je sais ma femme y est nous doit du blé
mais bon l'espagnol aussi on va y passer
le Portugal et il y aura la France vous
savez ça veut dire cacopedy en grec non
mauvais petit vous direz ça Amia
kukla ça veut dire poupée voilà très
bien ici quand même
merci beaucoup poli Caristo police et
pour dire non on fait OK
j'adore le grec
alors on va parler de votre vie de
Munich spiritions oui spiridions Léon
Farrugia spiridjan c'est énorme c'est
énorme c'est le prénom de mon grand-père
qui était musicien qui a été qui est qui
était qui est respons Dieu bon Dieu sur
la terre non c'était le le patriarche
comme on l'a connu dans en Méditerranée
avec le chapeau sur la tête au bout de
la table personne ne parlait avant qu'il
ait parlait etc
c'est pour ça que j'ai gardé s sur mes
cartes de visite Dominique Siri tu vas
réussir alors vous connaissez le 2
septembre 62 à Vichy d'une famille
d'origine maltaise votre grand-père
votre oncle votre père enfin c'était le
chef d'orchestre ouais ils sont tous
musiciens mes cousins on est une famille
de musiciens de musiciens comme la
boucherie voilà et alors votre famille
qui dit ici quand vous n'avez qu'à moi
pourquoi ils ont appris ce qui s'était
passé 20 ans avant non mais bon mon père
était mon père était chef d'orchestre
occasion de Vichy donc je suis né en
septembre fin de saison hop on rentre à
Paris
pour moi c'était le meilleur
candidat possible parce que je pensais
pas que c'est golem était possible était
capable de le faire vous avez été
nombreux à penser pareil mais moi je
suis pas déçu à l'inverse de pas mal
on en parlera tout à l'heure donc
vos parents quitte Vichy donc et il
monte à Paris ils ouvrent un bistrot à
Pigalle voilà c'est appelé le verdier
voilà et après ça fait chier Farrugia ah
ça c'est déjà mieux oui
votre frère
mais au moins on savait où c'était
alors vous arrêtez vos études en seconde
à 17 ans en seconde à 17 ans garde au
blé deux fois
en seconde à 17 ans
j'avais 16 ans et demi quand j'ai arrêté
j'ai pas 17 ça c'est une erreur dans la
biographie j'aurais pu dire que j'avais
le bac je l'ai pas je l'ai dit que
j'avais une naissance d'anglais personne
n'a jamais demandé
non non mais ça servait à rien je
faisais je faisais trois langues
vivantes français anglais russe
j'apprenais la flûte traversière c'est
pas ça qui allait me faire bouffer donc
je me suis dit bah mets-toi à travailler
maintenant donc j'ai fait plein de
petits boulots plein de petits boulots
tout en prenant des cours de batterie
quand même voilà parce que je voulais
être batteur de rock c'était mon dans
des groupes punk new wave
c'est que la boîte arrive est arrivé
juste en même temps
à l'époque il y avait que de la boîte à
ride partout début des années 80 les
épaulettes la boîte arrive bah oui
Jacque nord
de carreaux distributeur de prospectus
coursier à pied énorme pour scie à pied
à la Réunion aérienne qui était une
assurance d'aviation donc il ne fallait
pas apprendre une mobylette il y avait
une prime de chaussures c'est incroyable
de 200 francs tous les trois mois et
puis un jour donc votre rêve de pénétrer
dans le monde magique de l'entertainment
Dominique se réalisent enfin vous devez
standardiste Europe 1 mais à l'époque
Europe numéro 1 Europe numéro 1 c'était
un job d'étudiant donc voilà on a gagné
17 francs de l'heure et au répondait au
standard de jeu et là dès le début vous
êtes énorme quand on vous appelle en
disant allô c'est Europe 1 vous dites
c'est lui-même mais appelez-moi Pinpin
oui c'est ça
j'avais commencé la blague voilà après
Europe 1 d'ailleurs RTL
on monte en grade
et l'émission est réalisée par
Jean-Pierre Cancian dans la femme
Dominique ancien futur directrice des
variétés de TF1 cherchent un assistant
pour une nouvelle chaîne qui s'appelle
Canal+ et oui vous commencez au
bande-annonce et vous finirez président
directeur général un big up là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors vous commencez les cinq cartoon
avec Philippe Dana en 85 une histoire de
pot de miel c'est des trucs bidon qu'on
fait mais sur une chaîne qu'on regarde
pas à l'époque donc on peut tout tenter
voilà et moi j'ai compris que c'était
pas fait pour moi d'être devant je
n'étais pas mal devant après quand même
mais c'est pas de mon fait c'est de
grève qui a dit tiens on avait décidé de
faire un faux journal qui allait devenir
le JTN et ces deux grèves qui a dit
faroudia va faire la météo et donc quand
de grève dit faroudia va faire la météo
tout le monde dit oui monsieur et là
vous rencontrez Alain chabak vous
devenez ami le soir vous regardez
ensemble des cassettes de Saturday night
life évidemment ça donnera les nuls Avec
Carette et lobby ça s'est fait à peu
près comme ça après les Nuls vous vous
lancez dans la découverte de nouveaux
talents Kadéos Titeuf les Robins des
Bois Du Bosc et ensuite Manu Payet
Laurent la fuite c'est pas mal quand
même vous avez du flair non ouais du
coup aussi
c'est bon c'est pas mal alors en dehors
des nouveaux talents vous faites de la
production de films trafic d'influence
paparazzi excellent film
meilleur espoir féminin monsieur
Batignolles c'est pas mal merci c'est
vrai que ma collaboration avec avec
Junior c'était quelque chose de
prodigieux dans ma vie c'est la magie du
cinéma et c'est pour ça qu'on en fait
c'est que parfois on a ça parfois on a
le clone aussi que j'ai produit c'est
une bouse mais bon voilà c'est on n'a
pas on gagne pas à tous les coups voilà
alors vous créez des chaînes de télé
donc comédie Cuisine TV et en 2002 canal
vous rappelle j'ai d'abord directeur des
programmes donc plus PDG de la SA
ensuite retour à la prod avec les films
et les spectacles et aujourd'hui alors
Dominique on parle de vous pour France
Télévisions on parle de moi mais
personne n'a parlé donc si vous démontez
aussi catégoriquement ça prouve que
c'est complètement vrai
pourquoi on a parlé de vous autant aussi
fort je pense parce que d'une part j'ai
une franche amitié avec Courbis qu'on
sait que j'aime bien le président de la
République dans des places de garçons
qui passeront après et
que et que voilà on s'est dit tiens
peut-être il y a j'en sais rien ça a dû
être évoqué en tout cas moi on m'a pas
appelé vraiment
je sais pas si j'ai envie de remettre
les mains dans le cambouis parce qu'il
faut vraiment mettre les mains dans le
cambouis il y a un énorme boulot à faire
mais il y a un boulot intéressant vous
diriez pas non je ne sais pas à quoi je
dirais oui c'est plus ça qu'autre chose
voilà je rappelle le titre du film ça
s'appelle l'amour c'est mieux à deux et
le prochain c'est à 3 j'imagine non
Dominique ça devrait être la suite
normalement les accueillons hervez-vous
et Christophe a l'évêque
[Applaudissements]
Hervé Bourges bonsoir alors avez-vous je
vais été successivement président de TF1
de France de France 3 de RMC de Canal+
Afrique c'est pas une carrière c'est un
zapping oui vous avez raison oui surtout
que c'est venu comme ça voilà super
Hervé Bourges c'est Hervé bouge oui
vous avez été présente tellement de
trucs j'ai été président à vie
finalement non c'est votre boulot
65 ans on peut on peut plus être
président ah pour moi vous êtes
président toute ma vie en tout cas je
suis très heureux de vous recevoir
président parce que c'est vous et
Marie-France Brière qui m'avait fait
débuter à la télévision il y a 25 ans
mesdames messieurs
en 1985
et alors je me souviens toujours d'une
fois vous êtes venu à Tout le monde en
parle et vous m'avez dit Thierry j'aime
beaucoup je suis très content de vous
avoir mis à l'antenne j'aime beaucoup ce
que vous faites mais arrêtez de parler
du cabanisme
mais vous savez c'était excellent parce
que vous avez repris ça après chaque
fois
très bien Président vous savez comment
on dit quand même maintenant le truc
pour arriver à le prononcer comme ça
vous avez dû en fumer moi je suis sûr
et dites moi vous me parlez jamais de la
cacoïne
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir vous êtes ici ce soir pour une
pièce intitulée ciao amore dans laquelle
une femme féministe et italienne quitte
un mari ambitieux et paumé sans trop
savoir pourquoi c'est un truc sur Carla
Bruni et Nicolas Sarkozy non
nous dans la pièce nous sommes fidèles
mais ce ne sont que des rumeurs non
c'est
tout simplement
il a un peu la tête dans le sac c'est un
peu autiste au niveau des sentiments et
tout d'un coup il va bien falloir qu'ils
se pose des questions qui fassent le
flashback et tout ça se fait dans la
plus totale mauvaise foi c'est assez dur
à ces violents alors les questions
posées dans l'oeuvre sont pourquoi on
s'aime pour qu'on s'aime plus comment
faire pour s'aimer dans une société où
l'individualisme règne en maître voilà
c'est une comédie d'apparence
légère et
derrière on y met j'aime bien bosser
comme ça que les gens allaient limite
les gens rient et après ils comprennent
pourquoi ils ont ris bon c'est une pièce
de Jérôme letski qui était à la Gaîté
Montparnasse avec vous il y a Serena
reynaldi la belle italienne de Nice
People alors la rencontre avec Serena a
été primordiale dites-vous oui
quel sens
dans tous les sens dans tous les sens
on regarde à quoi ça ressemble
[Musique]
j'en ai marre de tes vaches
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pourquoi j'arrive pas à lui dire ça
on peut quand même pas se quitter comme
ça reste
boire un verre tu vois Justin ça te va
essayer de me [__]
pourquoi pourquoi
ça fait beaucoup de questions
[Musique]
je t'aime
[Applaudissements]
voilà ciao
ça marche bien en plus ça se passe ça se
passe très bien et ce qui c'est qui est
bien avec le théâtre c'est que de
représentation représentation les gens
disent souvent ils en est pas marre au
bout d'un moment non non
et ça bouge sans arrêt et un jour je
réussirai ma tentative de sodomie
alors il y a une autre actu Christophe
il y a deux jours j'ai célébré
l'anniversaire de l'élection de Nicolas
Sarkozy à l'Élysée en chantant donc
mille Colombes devant le Fouquet c'est
vrai qu'il est sorti du resto pour vous
dire c'est pas le malin toi
si tu as des couilles
oui oui tous les ans on fait les
gâteaux lâcher de colombes des
distributions de billets de 500 euros
pour relancer le pouvoir d'achat
l'année dernière
mouvement de résistance ludique des
Mille Colombes parce qu'on a été quand
même nous on a même encore des copains
qui sont dans le coma quand ils ont vu
arriver Mireille Mathieu place de la
Concorde mais il y a eu un à la décharge
de Sarkozy je crois que lui aussi il
n'était pas super content non non je
pense pas on voit leur tête d'ailleurs
sur la scène la tête de fion le Premier
ministre le quand on voit sa tête sur le
le quand on est là ils se disent mais
arrête pas de chanter
vous nous faites un petit mille Colombes
comme ça à capella
ça c'est la colombe
encore deux ans
depuis toujours
vous voulez pas vous présenter à la
présidence de la République trouve quand
même que il s'occupe de beaucoup de
choses qu'il est très présent sur le
terrain que ça a porté un dynamisme
assez extraordinaire et nouveau par
rapport à ces prédécesseurs mais que
trop en faire ça risque de gâcher le
plaisir des uns et des autres plutôt
quelqu'un qui gesticule il nous faudrait
quelqu'un qui qui fasse vraiment bouger
les choses mais tu vas me donner
quelqu'un qui va faire bouger les choses
et ça va me faire marrer tu vois
aujourd'hui malheureusement à gauche et
je te parle en tant que ex homme de
gauche il y a zéro proposition et on
travaille sur la retraite non on bougera
pas des 60 ans ok d'accord mais comment
on fait un moment donné je veux dire ça
fait trois ans que le capital n'est
absolument pas taxé donc ne serait-ce
que ça à dire le pognon il faut aller
chercher où il est tu as raison mais ça
n'était pas dans le programme du mec qui
a été élu
en tout cas le petit peuple entre
guillemets qui a voté pour lui je pense
qu'il ne le fera pas deux fois
on en reparlera bien
le problème il y a des gens qui l'ont
soutenu et qui sont barrés parce que sur
le meilleur moment de se barrer quand ça
va mal et moi j'ai envie d'être là au
moment justement où ça va aller pour
essayer de faire quelque chose pour que
ça bouge quand même bien on passe
maintenant aux commentaires de
l'actualité de la télé avec l'édito de
Blacko et c'est Emmanuel Beretta
responsable média au point version
papier et net que nous retrouverons sur
ce plateau après le magnéto
[Musique]
pauvre petit président Sarkozy il en a
tellement bavé pour arriver au sommet du
pouvoir et maintenant qu'il est tout en
haut et ben il peut même pas nommer
qu'il veut à la tête de France
Télévisions pourtant en juin 2008 il
avait décidé que cette tête à lui de
nommer le patron de France Télé écoutez
les choses doivent être clair quand même
il y a un actionnaire
cet actionnaire
[Musique]
un président désormais la télépublique
appartient officiellement au domaine
réservé de l’élysée en tant que chef des
armées le président est le seul à
pouvoir appuyer sur le bouton de l'arme
de destruction massive et ben la télé
c'est une arme de communication massive
seul le président peut appuyer sur le
bouton de la télécommande après tout ça
c'est toujours plus ou moins passé comme
ça sous Chirac c'est Patrick de Carolis
qui a été nommé à la tête de la
télépubique juste après avoir écrit un
livre d'entretien avec Bernadette Chirac
comme c'est mignon comme petite
coïncidence vous imaginez si aujourd'hui
Sarko me met un proche de Carla à la
tête de France Télévisions le scandale
après le fiston la tête de l'EPAD et
Henri Proglio à la tête de déesse notre
président est devenu tellement
impopulaire qui doit éviter toute
nouvelle tempête médiatique du coup pour
pas faire de vagues bah l'idéal faites
rien changé et donc de reconduire le
président actuel pour 5 ans le seul
problème
que Carolis a traité Sarkozy d’imbéciles
de menteurs enfin il a pas dit
exactement comme ça mais quand Sarkozy a
affirmé que les programmes du public
ressemblaient à ceux du privé Caroli SLA
bien cassé lorsqu'on dit qu'il n'y a pas
de différence entre la télévision de
service public ou les télévisions
privées je trouve cela faux je trouve
cela stupide et je trouve cela injuste
c'est incroyable aujourd'hui pour
décrocher un poste mieux vaut ne pas
appartenir au camp du président après
avoir nommé le socialiste Didier Migaud
à la tête de la commission des finances
de l'Assemblée après avoir nommé Michel
charas au Conseil constitutionnel
pourquoi notre président Me confirait-il
pas la direction de France Télévisions à
un gars qui a dit qu'il était stupide
voilà c'était l'émission de lacos mise
en images de Julien graff Emmanuel
Beretta bonsoir vous êtes responsable de
la rubrique médias au point et vous
publiez chez Fayard le hold-up de
Sarkozy int le Bing écoute tordu alors
le pitch c'est le hold-up de l'enfant de
la télé sur le service public de la
radio et de la télévision ça aurait pu
s'appeler Sarko le télécrate c'est
incroyablement bien documenté c'est
extrêmement précis à croire que vous
êtes partout comment vous faites
beaucoup de gens avaient intérêt à
parler au bout de 3 ans de président
Sarkozy et donc j'ai de bons témoins qui
qui ont alimenté une précision mais
j'essaye d'être dans les réunions à
Matignon chez Christina Albanel dans le
bureau de carolyse quand il apprend que
la pub va être supprimée j'essaie d'être
un peu dans tous ces endroits là
qu'est-ce qu'il se dit qu'est-ce qui se
fait oh il y a des moments
extraordinaires par exemple quand
Sarkozy va à France 3 le 30 juin 2008
donc ils s'engueule avec Caroline et ce
que j'ai appris en disant dans notre
bouquin c'est qu'il y a des
syndicalistes qui veulent enfoncer la
force et effectivement la porte qui qui
devait conduire au studio a été bloqué
par les les gardes du corps pendant que
de l'autre côté les syndicalistes avec
un bélier un bélier enfoncé la porte on
tenté de le faire
se verrous à sauter ça fait partie de
des choses que on n'a pas su parce que
pertinent il y a un truc aussi qui est
formidable c'est quand on doit nommer
quelqu'un la tête de l'audiovisuel
extérieur alors la couche nerf qui fait
j'ai bien une idée moi mais bon elle
voudra jamais
qui se déroule ou qui dort c'est ou
effectivement Kushner suggère le nom de
de Christine alors Christine c'est
Christine Albanel ou Christine Ockrent
tout le monde comprend que c'est
Christine Ockrent
il y a un mystère là dessus parce que
Christine Ockrent avait été reçu par
Sarkozy plusieurs mois auparavant elle
lui avait dit non on ne sait pas s'il
aidait vraiment sa femme on sait pas il
y a un mystère et alors il y a les amis
à caser alors ça c'est extraordinaire
les amis moi ce qui m'a le plus choqué
je dirais dans votre bouquin c'est
Christian Clavier à qui on demande de
jouer une pièce sur France 3 il demande
quand même 382000 euros pour jouer à
Molière et quand il fait le deuxième
Molière il redemande 382000 euros c'est
cool d'être ami avec Sarko quand même je
pense qu'il a hérité du contrat de
Michel Serrault qui est décédé et dont
il a appris la place au pied élevé tu
viens et tu prends un pied élevé et tu
me redonne le même contrat et tu dis oui
on aurait mis Henri en même temps il y
en a un des deux qui a du talent quoi
et les deux sont morts
mais mais
il y a une histoire marrante dans le
cinéma avec Thierry Lhermitte qui a
repris la place d'un autre acteur dans
le dîner de cons et enfin bon on ne
voulait pas de lui et la maison de
protection ne voulait pas de nuit et ils
ont été obligé de le prendre il a dit
d'accord mais c'est multi
et voilà il y a beaucoup d'acteurs qui
font ça alors il y a aussi évidemment la
suppression de la publicité ça c'est
extraordinaire parce que on sait
toujours pas comment ça va être financé
puisque Bruxelles ne veut pas qu'on taxe
les telko
là je suis désolé Dominique c'est un peu
l'improvisation générale de ce de ce
président il a un peu improvisé tout
cela lors d'une conférence de presse au
moment où il avait quelques problèmes à
garantir une augmentation du pouvoir
d'achat et l'improvisation mène au fait
que l'Europe nous dit non et qu'on ne
sait plus financer cette réforme là le
le vrai problème général c'est qu'on
n'arrivera jamais à taxer les Téléco et
si le problème de l'industrie cinéma
photographique française parce que
aujourd'hui c'est le piratage existe et
c'est grâce Zelko et l'été le coup filpa
un rond et le cinéma est en train de
mourir un petit feu à cause de ça aussi
l'Europe protège les telko exactement et
tu sais pourquoi parce qu'il y a un
lobbying très fort mais très puissant
ils étaient même à dire que l'Internet
devait être comme l'eau et là tout d'un
coup ils sont aperçu que c'était gratuit
tu vois non on l'enlève on l'enlève on
enlève alors Sarkozy va choisir lui-même
le président de France Télévisions à la
place du CSA et nous on nous dit en fait
le CSA choisissait rien du tout tout ça
c'était arrangé d'avance alors Hervé
vous qui avez été président du CSA c'est
vrai que vous serviez à rien on est dans
Sarkozy a pris cette décision il est
chef d'État je pense que c'est quand
même une erreur et une faute c'est une
faute d'abord parce que c'est un recul
des libertés moi ce que je peux vous
dire c'est que quand j'entends les gens
qui soient sont de mauvaise foi soit ne
sont pas qualifiés soit
son mal informés dire que c'était une
grande hypocrisie le pouvoir je vais
vous donner moi non pas des des
principes mais des faits puzzle quand il
était à Radio France Internationale
alors là c'est avec un autre pouvoir il
est il est en fin de mandat et il y
avait à l'époque le président Chirac et
le Premier ministre période de
cohabitation qui était Jospin et
Monsieur Lionel Jospin nous fait savoir
qu'il souhaiterait que pour RFI un tel
un tel remplace l'usel nous ne sommes
réunis et nous avons pensé que les noms
qu'on nous proposait ne valaient pas le
président en place et nous avons j'ai
été voir Monsieur Jospin je lui dis
voilà midi mais l'actionnaire souhaite
que je dis mais c'est ça ne suivra pas
alors voilà pardonnez-moi monsieur le
Président mais
on va dire car on sait le lobbying qu'on
fait et Madame Chirac et la fille de
Jacques Chirac auprès de Jacques Chirac
afin que Carole soit là donc voilà
le CSA était peut-être une institution
imparfaite mais au moins il y avait une
prise de distance aujourd'hui le fait
que ça soit le président qui nomme
directement ça le met lui Nicolas
Sarkozy dans une position infernale
puisqu'il est soupçonné d'être celui qui
va tirer les ficelles on va le
soupçonner de faire ça à Radio France de
faire ça d'où le président de Radio
France et le directeur des programmes de
France Inter voilà maintenant faire
depuis plusieurs mois c'est attribué à
nouveau pouvoir qui le piège résultat il
fait de cette nomination un test
politique majeur de ce quinquennat sur
une question quand même finalement assez
accessoire par rapport au problème des
Français aujourd'hui à l'Elysée quand il
reçoivent des candidats pour diriger
France Télévision on leur demande qui va
faire le journal télévisé il veut nommer
une équipe un pas seulement un président
il veut nommer une équipe est-ce que
c'est la tribution d'un président de la
République de définir la ligne
éditoriale de France Télévisions vous
savez Emmanuel qu'on parle de Dominique
pour les pour les programmes c'est au
courant de ça vous l'avez appelé pour
lui demander s'il vous plaît
je pense qu'il est assez sincère parce
qu'il faut faire une chaîne avec Patrick
Sabatier les frères Bogdanov Pierre Sled
à la place d'arrêt de chapeau et David
Hallyday comme producteur est-ce que
vous prenez David Hallyday je pense que
il sera directement au top management
parmi les folies que la Sarkozy le fait
qu'il a rencontré David Hallyday et qui
lui a proposé la direction des variétés
de France Télévisions ce qu'il a refusé
d'ailleurs totalement fou parce que
exprès de l'autre côté du chèque pour
conclure ce qu'il faut quand même savoir
ça va t'épouver ça Christophe c'est
qu'en fait donc
Sarkozy n'est pas arrivé à vendre David
Hallyday à Patrick de Caroli et depuis
Johnny Hallyday prend plus Sarkozy au
téléphone et Sarkozy s'en plainte comme
extraordinaire
ça par rapport au chômage c'est terrible
alors Hervé vous êtes président donc du
Comité permanent de la diversité de
France Télévisions et dans le rapport
que vous avez rendu public vous dites
France Télévisions n'est pas encore la
télévision de tous les Français vous
plaignez qu'en fait par exemple Audrey
Pulvar qui présentait le 19/20 sur
France 3 n'est pas été remplacé après
son départ sur i-Télé pour vous
aujourd'hui il y a pas assez de couleurs
sur France Télévision ça c'est une
évidence regardez la rue ils sont tous
en prison
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
regardez la rue et regardez la
télévision est-ce que la télévision et
le reflet de la rue non il s'agit pas de
dire on va changer les choses de façon
considérable on va faire une politique
de quota qui serait une bêtise et qui ne
privilégierait pas la compétence mais il
faut quand même arriver à rééquilibrer
alors qu'est-ce qu'on a demandé on a
demandé d'abord un acte symbolique qui
n'a rien à voir avec les quotas qu'on
puisse dans un des grands journaux avoir
quelqu'un qui représente cette diversité
deuxièmement il faut et c'est peut-être
le plus important au niveau du
recrutement avoir des gens qui est un
petit peu cette mentalité d'ouverture
d'esprit or là vous trouvez toujours des
gens qui se reproduisent à l'identique
qu'est-ce que vous voulez un énarque qui
va penser à un énarque regardez
Christine Kelly Rachid arabe dès qu'ils
ont réussi on les a mis au CSA voilà
diversité au CSA est-ce que c'est vrai
que le CSA compte les non blancs à
l'antenne oui dans les quand la
comptabilité qui est faite parce que il
y a un problème de l'interdiction par la
constitution de dire que les gens sont
aussi où cela alors ils ont trouvé ce
qui est là mais Nagui par exemple vous
le mettez dans quoi vous Nagui je le
mets dans les bains bons animateurs de
télévision
[Applaudissements]
et là c'est à ça qu'il faut arriver
faire ce qui s'est fait finalement aux
Etats-Unis vous trouvez dans aux
États-Unis dans un certain nombre de
création audiovisuelle des gens qui sont
procureurs qui sont en médecins qui sont
juges etc il se trouve qu'ils sont noirs
vous les regardez pas comme noir mais
ayant ça Hervé Bourges jamais quand même
si la sous représentation des classes
populaires si par exemple les ouvriers
mais en 23 % de la population française
à la télé ils ont deux pour cent et les
cas qui représentent 15% la population
française la télé 161%. donc j'irai pas
avant mais parallèlement à la
représentation de la diversité il faut
devoir aussi la représentation des
classes populaires pour nous la
diversité c'est aussi la diversité
sociale c'est une évidence essayer de
s'emparer de cette question de la
diverticité sociale
il exige maintenant des chaînes qu'elles
soient balayées dans tous les programmes
voilà pas seulement la fiction mais
également l'info alors comment on fait
pour équilibrer un JT avec toutes les
catégories sociales de la population
par exemple ils ont ils ont demandé par
exemple pour les micro-trottoirs quand
on vend de leur avis aux gens dans la
rue comment on fait pour savoir qui est
ouvrier qui est cadre etc alors ils ont
une ligne de conduite qui est ce qu'elle
est c'est quand on porte une cravate on
est cadres quand on ne porte pas on est
tout le reste est-ce qu'on n'arrive pas
quand même à des absurdités là oui mais
est-ce que le JT qui représente le mieux
la diversité sociale c'est la suite
Jean-Pierre Pernaut finalement
on arrive à des actions
à faire en tous les cas Emmanuel merci
d'avoir été avec nous ça s'appelle le
Sarkozy c'est très bien informé c'est
parfait je vous le conseille c'est
publié chez Faya merci d'avoir été avec
nous et nous accueillons Stéphane
Guillon
ça va ça va très bien alors en l'honneur
d'Hervé un spécial télé ce soir en
l'honneur de Monsieur Bourges absolument
à vous Stéphane pour la semaine dernière
[Musique]
en novembre dernier souvenez-vous Gérard
Holtz monde sur les planches dans une
pièce d'arold Pinter ce n'était pas une
animation pour le Téléthon non non
malheureusement Gérard est resté sur
scène plusieurs semaines
pour le sommet de Copenhague Laurence
Ferrari était parti avec une équipe de
TF1 au Groenland sur place la
journaliste c'était écrit le
réchauffement est une réalité pour
transporter une équipe de TF1 au
Groenland comptait 300000 tonnes de CO2
Laurence Ferrari la preuve par l'exemple
prend de l'avion ni que la banquise
[Musique]
en novembre toujours Arielle Dombasle
préside le jury Miss France 2010 très
bon choix quoi de mieux qu'une vraie
beauté naturelle sans la moindre
retouche pour incarner cette cérémonie
en décembre André Manoukian pose nu pour
le calendrier du Secours populaire faut
arrêter les conneries là non franchement
41% de dons en moins pour les
associations cette année tu envoies un
chèque en retour tu reçois une photo de
Manoukian à poil après tu donnes plus
c'est normal
pour la première fois cette année Canal+
à sous-titré un porno pour les sourds et
malentendants s'il y a bien un genre où
le sous-titre est inutile c'est la
pornographie la levrette c'est
universelle une fellation par exemple
quoi qu'il arrive la fille ne peut pas
parler
c'est canal quoi 25 ans cette année il
se cherche
[Musique]
Marc-Olivier Fogiel Nikos Aliagas et
Lara Fabian ont enregistré un album au
profit de la lutte contre le sida il a
rien compris Pierre Berger l'importance
des dons n'est pas liée à la maladie le
Téléthon un enfant malade c'est émouvant
tu donnes faut Gilles qui chante avec
les deux autres c'est un télé
une très belle phrase de Marie Drucker
la liberté guide mes choix à quand un
recueil des plus belles phrases de Marie
Drucker la liberté guide mes choix
pour la première fois la chaîne
religieuse Antoine TV a embauché deux
speakerines alors moi j'ai un petit
faible pour celle de droite je la trouve
plus sexy plus souriante un petit
alpétit quoi celle de gauche un petit
côté glacial figé on dirait Valérie
Pécresse j'aime moins
en janvier après le tremblement de terre
d'Haïti George Clooney s'engage pour
aider les victimes en France
Pascal Obispo
milles excuses haïtiens les dons ont été
beaucoup moins importants
[Musique]
en ouverture du concert spécial Haïti
diffusé sur France 2 Frédéric Mitterrand
a voulu lire un poème haïtien bonsoir
c'est une voilure d'elle sauvage emporte
l'île vers les naufrages c'est le
crépuscule noir l'envol déchiré d'un
dernier mouchoir et si le cri blesse
l'oiseau tu partiras
refus catégorique de France Télévisions
ils ont beau être aux ordres du
gouvernement quand c'est trop chiant ils
disent non
en mars Nathalie Marquay rêve de jouer
au théâtre avec Jean-Pierre Pernaut
ça s'appelle un cauchemar
[Applaudissements]
en avril un animateur télé britannique
meurt par asphyxie lors d'un jeu sexuel
en solitaire nous en France on a un
animateur télé adepte des jeux sexuels
en solitaire mais bon il fait gaffe quoi
attention
et on termine par une excellente
nouvelle Paris Première diffusera des
films de cul après les matchs de la
Coupe du Monde ce serait bien que nos
joueurs participent à une mauvaise
prestation sur le terrain et après on
les retrouverait dans un domaine où ils
excellent le vrai esprit professionnel
cunnilingus il reste quand même de très
très bons techniciens merci beaucoup
merci voilà on retrouve très bonne lions
ici le 29 mai et d'ici là sur canal+.fr
alors mes amis on a beaucoup parlé des
agriculteurs dernièrement il y a 15
jours des milliers d'entre eux sont
venus crier leur détresse dans les rues
de Paris nous avons donc décidé ce soir
de rediffuser le témoignage extrêmement
émouvant de Pierre Priolet producteur de
fruits dans le sud de la France on
regarde
pierre bonsoir bonsoir alors vous avez
fait une entrée fracassante donc sur la
scène médiatique le 17 décembre dernier
vous écoutez ce jour-là la matinale de
France Inter ou le ministre
d'agriculture Bruno Le Maire est invité
le ministre parle de la chute des
revenus des paysans en 2009 - 34%
de l'organisation des marchés des aides
à distribuer vous écoutez tout ça mais
intérieurement vous bouillonnez vous
enragez et vous décidez sans vraiment de
raison particulière d'appeler France
Inter vous dites j'ai appelé sans trop
savoir pourquoi j'en pouvais plus
d'entendre ces conneries quand on
appelle on sait jamais pourquoi en
sachant très bien que des milliers de
Français appellent des milliers de
Français ont des problèmes on se dit
mais tu appelles ça sert à rien alors
pierre vous avez toujours travaillé dans
le monde agricole mais c'est au début
des années 90 quand la grande
distribution ne veut plus acheter au
grossiste mais au producteurs que vous
décidez de vous lancer dans la
production de pommes et de poires à ce
moment-là vous achetez très hectares de
terrain à Molène en Provence mais pour
commencer à récolter il faudra attendre
10 ans
mais disons que dans la vie moderne ça
paraît fou oui le monde agricole a
l'habitude de travailler sur le long
terme le monde agricole travaille pour
ses enfants pour ses petits-enfants
c'est vrai qu'on est une race en voie de
disparition clairement alors au total
vous allez investir 600000 euros c'est
quand même beaucoup d'argent alors la
commercialisation de vos poires de vos
pommes comment sont 2000 et jusqu'en
2010 il y a pendant 10 ans
l'exploitation n'est bénéficiaires que
deux ans c'est exact en 2009 c'est
particulièrement catastrophique donc
vous avez des pertes qui s'élèvent à
120.000 euros vous êtes obligé de vendre
un bâtiment d'exploitation exacte pour
récupérer ce pognon quoi pour pouvoir
payer des les annuités des dettes
pourquoi vous en arrivez là c'est
malheureusement très simple donc vous
vendez vous 17 centimes d'euros le kilo
des poires qui déjà vous coûte 40
centimes d'euros déjà vous vendez à
perte moi je croyais que c'était
interdit de vendre à perte tout à fait
quand les grandes compagnies vendent à
perdre Bruxelles les condames à des très
lourdes peines pour le monde agricole en
général c'est une logique tellement
banale que plus personne n'y fait
attention alors le pire de tout c'est
pas que vous sentiez les poires 17 alors
qu'elle vous coûte 40 centimes c'est que
vous vous les retrouvez ces points à
2,80 euros voire trois euros dans les
grandes surfaces
et effectivement la marge du
distributeur elle est de combien la
marge de distributeur aujourd'hui la
marge d'un épicier ce que vous êtes en
train de nous dire en fait c'est que ces
grandes surfaces marges comme des
épiciers de quartier quoi tout à fait
ouais tout à fait donc ils ont pu du
tout leur vocation de grandes surfaces
c'est-à-dire de permettre aux gens de
payer moins cher en gros c'était ça au
départ
ayant éliminé tous les commerces des
centres-villes il se trouve seul à
proposer la marchandise un grand
responsable m'a dit mais qu'est-ce que
tu crois le consommateur qui rentre dans
mon magasin
jusqu'à laquelle je peux plumer il va
pas aller faire 40 km pour trouver une
poire à 20 centimes moins cher il est là
il paye il se passe
quand j'ai entendu le ministre parlé des
34% de perte de revenus
j'étais en colère parce qu'en fait pour
perdre du revenu pour perdre 34 % ils
font déjà en avoir un bien sûr donc
c'est absurde vous croyez qu'il le sait
Bruno Le Maire ça mais non le maire
j'ai l'impression de vivre sur une autre
planète on se jette des arguments on
fait croire aux gens qui a deux camps
mais il y a pas de camp il y a deux
camps qui veulent accéder au pouvoir
mais nous 50% de la population ne vote
pas tous ces gens qui sont sans voix et
qu'on cherche même pas à attirer alors
le pire était à venir parce que non
seulement les les prix sont faibles mais
ces prix vous les connaissez pas qu'on
vous vendez c'est-à-dire que vous vendez
vos fruits à des organisations de
producteurs à des centrales d'achat qui
eux les vendent à la grande distribution
et et en fait ces centrales d'achat il y
en a il y en a très peu il y a 300 000
producteurs il y a très peu de de
l'achat et en fait vous savez ce que
vous avez gagné une fois que la centrale
d'achat a vendu à la grande distribution
on leur pose des produits on a aucun
prix tout ce qu'on sait c'est qu'ils
vont vendre et comme ils disent au mieux
vaut mieux mais l'organisation se paye
déduit ses frais et donne le reste au
producteurs un exemple hier je pose la
question combien on vend les Golden on
me dit 45 centimes quand vous enlevez
les frais il reste 1 centime aux
producteur en fait cadeau de vos pommes
quoi voilà l'avenir c'est quoi parce que
vous avez 57 ans bientôt c'est la
retraite à la retraite vous allez gagner
687,16 euros par mois c'est ce qu'on
appelle un double peine c'est-à-dire que
tous les collègues qui travaillent ont
très souvent de travailler 46 ans de
leur vie ils ont consacré 46 ans à
embellir la nature à produire des fruits
à produire de la nourriture à toute la
population
ils font 8 heures à 14 heures travail
jour les trois quarts sans week-end les
trois cas très peu de congés à la fin de
leur vie de travail on leur dit monsieur
vous avez enfin droit à la retraite et
vous avez droit à 600 97 euros 16 c'est
une double peine c'est un mépris absolu
donc un paysan aujourd'hui c'est un mec
qui vend la plupart du temps à perdre un
type qui a une retraite misérable après
avoir fait un boulot épuisant toute sa
vie c'est un type qui passe pour un
dingue parce que quand on le voit à la
télé il déverse du fumier il déverse du
lait il déverse des fruits donc les gens
qui voient ça ils disent c'est des
cinglés c'est un type qui vit de
subventions publiques alors que c'est
pas vrai alors que vous vous en avez pas
c'est un type en plus qu'on traite de
pollueurs parce qu'on dit avec les
pesticides vous polluez les nappes
phréatiques donc aujourd'hui non
seulement vous gagnez pas de blé vous
travaillez pour rien et en plus vous
avez une image de merde donc
aujourd'hui un paysan c'est un Danner de
la terre comme on disait de Menton voilà
disons que on pourrait plutôt résumer en
exploiter agricole c'est un exploiter
agricole
alors
qu'est-ce qui vous fait tenir par
rapport à ça
vous savez les paysans c'est la dernière
race qui pense à leurs enfants alors
petits enfants
vous voyez notre société elle ne pense
qu'au profit immédiat on est prêt à
gagner n'importe quoi sur n'importe qui
pourvu que ça soit rapide
l'agriculteur quand il plante
l'agriculteur quand il investit dans des
animaux l'agriculteur quand il arrive à
concevoir son exploitation il fait un
acte de création on n'est pas des
jouisseurs on a face à notre face à nous
une société de jouisseur où tout est
permis et quand on achète des produits
en Chine ou on sait très bien que
l'enfant gagne 5 centimes de l'heure on
s'en fout c'est moins cher je crois que
le vrai débat c'est un vrai débat de
fond l'agriculteur a envie de mettre
l'homme au cœur de la vie au cœur de la
société et si on est attaché à notre
métier c'est qu'il y a des races
on est en plein direct
les politiques qui peuvent vous aider
pierre pas comme ça non j'ai entendu des
bas tout à l'heure j'avais envie de me
tirer une balle dans la tête ouais
ça serait une solution intelligente
parce qu'en fait il parle d'eux il parle
pas de nous moi je dis on a des
difficultés mais j'ai conscience qu'il y
a des ouvriers qui se lèvent l'âme toute
leur vie qui ont jamais la moindre
reconnaissance ni de la société ni de
leur société j'ai l'impression et l'état
des milliers de chômeurs qui arrivent en
fin de droit qui sont dans notre
situation
alors vous dites pierre que vous avez
vous dites pierre vous avez envie de
vous tirer une balle dans la tête est-ce
que vous avez pas envie d'aller tirer
une balle dans la tête des gens qui vous
exploitent comme ça ça sert à rien il y
a eu déjà cris dans le temps quand même
je pense que toute façon on est dans une
crise qu'on nous cache à force de mentir
à tout le monde on croit ses mensonges
c'est ça qui m'inquiète la chance de
l'agriculteur c'est qu'il est seul dans
son champ il réfléchit il a pas de de
brouillage à sa réflexion et quand on
réfléchit qu'on observe qu'on arrive à
créer de l'argent avec du vide j'observe
un bénéfice de 50 milliards de la BNP
cette année j'ai vraiment le sentiment
de vivre au pays des faux-monnayeurs
parce que l'argent c'est le travail le
travail c'est l'outil on oublie c'est
ces vérités première et quand on fera
les vrais comptes quand on s'apercevra
que le pays est à l'arrêt et que tous
ces milliards annoncés sont du vent on
verra à quel point c'était important
d'être les pieds dans les racines donc
on souffle on sait qu'on souffre on sait
qu'on est pas les seuls à souffrir il y
a énormément de gens qui travaillent dur
qui sont méprisés pas considérés un déni
d'existence et c'est ce déni d'existence
qu'il faut qu'on dénonce c'est pas tirer
une balle dans la tête de quelqu'un de
toute façon si ça continue comme ça
l'occasion à tout sera donné mais nous
c'est pas de dire non on a des solutions
c'est pour ça qu'il faut qu'on qu'on
arrête une solution qui est une solution
en tous les cas ça serait de rendre
constructible une toute petite partie
des terrains agricoles ce qui déjà
financerait vos exploitations il
suffirait de changer un peu le le plan
d'occupation des sols et puis c'est tout
hein aujourd'hui il faut changer que ça
donne il faut qu'on accède enfin aux
consommateur on a tous des une petite
partie de terrain qui est convoitée par
quelqu'un qui veut mettre sa maison et
que nous ne pouvons pas le faire on
mettrait 1000 mètres carrés par
exploitant agricole 330
000 exploitants agricoles 40% de cette
somme serait donnée à la trésorerie de
l'agriculture pour lui permettre de
respirer et 60% de cette forme somme
serait consacré à un fond où les
actionnaires seraient les agriculteurs
se font permettrait d'acheter des
magasins à peu près 200 ou 300
simplement pour vendre aux consommateurs
à prix coûtant
directement auprès des consommateurs ça
nous permettrait dans tous les quartiers
difficiles d'embaucher un chômeur de 55
ans qui est capable qui est compétent de
le mettre dans le magasin avec un vrai
CDI de prendre trois jeunes du quartier
sans qualification de 18 à 20 ans donc
personne veut de leur donner leur chance
de les employer avec des CDI pour avoir
des vraies qualifications et nous ça
nous permettrait enfin de communiquer en
réalité sur nos produits sur le vrai
prix que coûte notre production ce
projet
il est fou mais je pense que si on n'a
pas de folie dans la vie il vaut mieux
disparaître bravo merci de votre
témoignage
[Applaudissements]
alors Elisabeth Guigou il se trouve que
votre père était arboriculture au Maroc
et qu'au moment de la décolonisation il
s'était installé en Provence on les
vergers de Provence c'est une région que
vous connaissez très bien et c'est un
métier aussi que vous connaissez bien il
est venu début des années 60 il a planté
des pêches les péchés j'ai beaucoup
endettés il a eu quelques années où il a
pu rembourser ses dettes et puis après
ces produits ce que vous décrivez de
toute façon donc le verger a été il a
arraché il a refusé lui toujours
d'adhérer un groupement de producteurs
en raison de ce que vous dites ce qui
pensait que c'était il y avait trop de
frais généraux etc c'est c'est quelque
chose de terrible moi je me souviens
d'avoir vu mon père pleurait un soir il
y avait de la grêle toute la production
en l'espace d'une heure
j'ai jamais vu mon père pleurait sauf ce
jour-là
voilà donc c'est ça quand même savoir
c'est ça alors il y a quand même un
espoir parce que je trouve que cette
proposition de dire les agriculteurs se
groupent et ils font leur propre magasin
et ils vont vendre directement aux
consommateurs moi je pense que c'est
quelque chose à venir ça mon frère qui
est arboriculteur sur la même
propriétaire avec ma sœur aujourd'hui
ils vont faire ça les consommateurs ils
vont commencer à se rendre compte quand
même que c'est absurde on achète les
pommes en Chine maintenant on achète les
poires je crois en Afrique du Sud les
kiwis au Chili la moyenne de voyage des
fruits aujourd'hui dans le monde elle
est de 2500 km le bilan carbone c'est
fou
il nous a décrit un système qui nous
paraît à tous d'une simplicité d'un
naturel incroyable et il nous dit à la
fin de sa démonstration je sais c'est
fou je pense qu'on y arrivera pas alors
que on en est arrivé à penser que ce que
vient de nous décrire pierre est fou
alors que les pommes qu'on achètent et
qui font des milliers de kilomètres qui
font le tour du monde et qui sont en
plus pas bonnes plus cher ça ça serait
naturel alors qu'on comprend bien que
c'est ça c'est la solution la solution
n'est pas très compliquée ça fait quoi
40 ou 50 ans que le mépris a commencé
c'est-à-dire que tout ce qui était de la
terre tout ce qui était manuel etc
c'était le dernier des cons qui faisait
ça c'était un imbécile je veux dire on
voulait pas que nos enfants soient
ouvriers on voulait pas qu'ils soient
plombier que ça peut électricien qui
soit pas cultivateur genre moi je vois
dans mon petit village d'aubrayville je
veux dire mes copains cultivateurs ils
ont eu des filles qui veulent absolument
pas faire ce métier pourquoi parce que
l'image des choses que ça nous renvoie
ne nous plaît pas et que dès que vous
voulez faire un cap des ministeries ou
de plomberie ou de qui voulait être
agriculteur on vous prend pour le roi
des cons quand on voit pierre on se rend
compte que c'est pas parce que
c'est sûr
il faut dire que le milieu agricole a
énormément changé dans ces 40 dernières
années tous les collègues agriculteurs
sont tous des techniciens agricoles les
trois quarts sont des gens qui ont
quasiment des niveaux d'ingénieurs ou
tout du moins de cadre qui ont
transformé la France merci en tous les
cas de votre témoignage et à vous en
tous les cas vraiment
voilà c'était Salut les Terriens avec
hervez-vous pour l'ensemble de son œuvre
Dominique Farrugia pour l'amour c'est
mieux à deux en salle actuellement
allez-y c'est très sympa Christophe
balenet pour Charles amandes
Emmanuel Beretta pour le réserve de
Sarkozy chez Fayard voilà merci à toute
l'équipe qui m'a aidé à faire cette
émission on se retrouve le 29 mai et
d'ici là sur canal+.fr voilà je vous
laisse avec le foot Salut les Terriens
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ne rien rater de innarditube
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu